good afternoon, speaking a bit about
css grids for those who do not know it, it
is a new layout it is a new way of
organizing the other page it is something that
is still quite green but
you will see that it has enormous potential
and it is good for me  I am fascinated by the
truth, it is very, very good,
start first,
ariel, I am an energy developer, I have been
working for almost five years,
I went through many companies before,
before that, I went
through many of the things that
we all go through when
fighting with the code  this one worked with
flash like many of you will have
also worked this pass through the
tables like many others will have also
passed and then well came the new
way of building sites with dips with
css this one that makes things a little easier for us
and now something better is coming  future
I hope that this is the future
because the truth is that the villas are very good
so how do we make a grid we are going to
think about it first p  we can say that it is
a new way that allows us to define
a structure where we have rows and
columns for this item or we can choose what to
put in each column in each row in
a very easy way now we are going to see
we have a normal grid as many
people  Something as simple as this will have happened
that we can hang it in many
ways we can
grab a game rub it joins the
left to the right make the clicker
of the putter and well this is going to work
like everywhere now grids what it
proposes is to think about this  another way
we have several basic concepts that we need
to understand before we start
wailing a bit on the css
one of them is grit lines chris lines
can i mean what we can see
exactly what are all the
red lines
that are basically what makes up  the
grid are horizontal or vertical
on the other hand we are seeing the
numbered ones
there are six lines for the rows and
four lines for the columns
on the other hand we have grid track that
would be the area that is between two
lines between two grid lines in this case there
is this creature that contains the
content and the side
grisel which is a unit the smallest unit
that we can find within
the grids, which is precisely all the
content that is between 4
games
and shouting, since it is basically the same
as a red track, only that it can
contain several grip cels, in this case
we are talking about shouting and footer,
now we will see it later on
what
this looks like is very related
to a concept that we are going to see a
little later
how we define a grid well
following the previous example in this
case we have 44 dips sandro a
container
and we define for the contaminate a new
type of display that describes  what this is
going to do is treat all the direct children
of that container
as a grid so far we
don't have anything we have the definition and the
elements are not yet positioned
in that grid because we have to
say it by css
so here we have a couple of concepts
to see if I can do it in
addition to display grid we have two
properties
with template rose and template columns
this is what we are going to say is the
definition of how many columns and
how many rows I am going to have and what
size in this case what I am
defining for example is
the first road is going to be 200 pixels
later it will have another 35 another
420 another 35 and finally  one of 200 and
for the columns there are going to be three
columns about 740 135 and another of 185
then there are basic properties
basically I am centering the
container in a width of 960 and
basic style properties for the
elements for the children of that
container
something important we can  use flex
inside those containers
this is simply using them to center
the elements both on the x-axis and on
the axis
this we do see
we have the same values as of  we define
in the css a column of 740 another of 35
that would be this space between the
content of the output and another of 800 185
the same for rows 235 420 35 and 200
we identify each grid with
a number as we see each greenline here
why do we do this
that number is going to tell us where
we want to position each element
we have these four properties that
we are now going to see they can be written in
another way in principle we have shout
to start grip volume grit rose start and
dear and robben
basically what we are  saying
is I want you to start in the grid
in line
1 as for the column and end in
4 I want it to start in row 1 and
end in row 2 the same for the
other elements in all defined
and if we see this example
huge
a
very difficult
and complicated company
I think I'm going to have to change the
resolution
let's try for
a moment things that happen
I don't know that it doesn't want to work
ok
to do something  or I'm going to do something very
easy is
I have problems with the resolution
if you let me
go down I'm going to change the resolution very easily
that's how the power is
this time the display is perfect it
is
and it's better
well I don't know if you can see a lot but I
hope much less  you see
this
good we are
good after a bit of trying how
good we have then
and as you can see
the definitions and we have
our perfectly armed shore
now
this same this same syntax we
can write it in a way
we can also say directly written alum
and grid road in  where the first value is
the grid, which would be the cry you
like, and in the second value, which would be the
cry lumen
and the same for the other,
we separate them by a with a Navarrese flash
and it is a slightly simpler way,
let's say  describe the same thing we can
do something else even a little more
than for me it is more complicated
actually I would use this in general but
well you can directly define a
c  rit area where the syntax is grid
rose start virtual long start grid
robben grip volume I actually
like it
better this way because it seems a bit
more understandable to me but well this is another
way to define where
our
good content goes so far  what we saw is
a grid in which we specify,
let's say, the gap that would be the
margin between each of the
elements and we had to specify it
directly here in the grid row and the
cry of the 35 pixels refers to
these  35 pixels and these 35 pixels
which is not so good because the truth
could be better we could mean well
I have this gap and I just want to
take into account the real columns
and real rows without having to
specify that margin well luckily
my life to the rescue
but it's a greek property in this
case this value is taking the 35
pixels for both the road and the
column
but we could basically change it and
put  a different gap for columns than
for rows but this allows us to
simplify this whole system a little
and now it is much more readable
we have three rows and two columns and the
gap is specified with this
property
therefore our graph would be a
little more simplified  basically we would have to
count that the second
wickline would be this same one, it is
like we
are putting the gap directly in the css
so we would have nothing more than 4 grit
lines for the rows and 3 for
the columns
, therefore our being is also
changed a little  but this basically
the same thing looks the same way
we may also like to use the word
funk this will ring a bell if you ever
work with span rose pan tables
well this this this syntax the levels
we're saying is i want you to start
at column 1 and expand  over
the second is also the same as putting
1/3 is another way to describe it
in this case the future and the header as
they are both being exposed to more than
one column they carry this key
I can also put names to each
of those
and lines
are put to 5 chetes it would be like
a parameter
this would be the name of the first of the
first row it has 200 pixels the name
of  the second 420 the name the third and
we do the final name to the row the
same for the columns
then also in the css we can
directly specify that
line name instead of having to explain
numerically
each one of the rules and this added up is
quite  good because it allows you to
remember a little more you don't have to
be paying attention to which is the line
in which I had to add well with
these quite descriptive names
we can specify
in the same way and this code will
always be the same anyway this
You see it and it will continue to be exactly the
same as it was before,
the fruit is missing, which is a little bad, it
seems to me that it was missing,
so I put the align justif  and
well
we can also do this specify
the same name the same here for the
columns and for the rows they
all share the same let's say the
same
and what we specify directly is
that name and the line number
so
you can realize that ingrid row for
example  the only thing that is said
specify is road because
if we go to the example
again
in this case it says rose 1 start that
we are talking about the header it is
saying that I want it to start on the
first line no I did not have to specify
the second line because the algorithm
understands  that once you specify
the beginning it will go yes or yes until the
second line unless we
specify that it go further, that is why
in this case
we had to specify it but if not the
soul understands in all cases with the
columns it is the same as  it was going to occupy
until the next line we
cannot specify anything else with the
first with the first call and nothing else
until now we were seeing
axis  Examples of an explicit grid in
which we define
in the css the size that the
columns and rows are going to have, what happens if
we add more elements have
extra tips added
how are those tips
going to be seen well let's see the  For example,
I added 4 extra dips with more
content. What
the grid algorithm does is it is
going to try to
apply the same
definitions that we said in the
container to the other elements. Then,
as it knows that they are two columns, it
directly positioned them in both
columns and if I keep adding two it
will keep adding it in the same way
that is because the algorithm is
intelligent and knowing how to position the
elements even when they are outside the
explicit grid this would be precisely
then we are talking about and implicitly what
the grid is by  out of the definition that
we gave the css
now
we have two more properties that we can
use which are grid auto rose and auto
columns this property is what  e
allow me is to specify to the
implicit grid that I value is going to have in
terms of height and already uidd those new
elements that are in the
implicit grid so in this case I am
telling you that all my rows that
you think are outside of  that
explicit grid has a value of 500
pixels and that all my columns have
a value of 200 pixels
then it exists we see it
is the same example
then our content has
500 pixels
and 200 pixels as we said here
we can change this calmly
and now our content  it has 100
because the same is presented to them for the
columns
we can also do another very
interesting thing that are esther bits that is,
they are grids inside the grid
in this example that if you take
inside maine which is our
main content we have 3 sub contents
quite simple
to those that in that same container I
defined that it is a condition that is going to be
grid so all the elements
are  inside they will also be gray
ians in this case I added a padding
of 10 pixels to separate it a little
from its container and a gray gap of 10
pixels for both columns and
rows
and here we are introducing a new
concept that is this from fr that  it would
be a fraction which is a fraction well I
am telling you that my columns are to
occupy
a fraction that is to say that there are two
fractions of the fraction it would be
the blank space that I have left in the
container so I say I want
there to be two blank spaces  and this is going
to calculate
automatically
if we see it
we have 3 we are
going to see the properties so
we understand how it is positioned by its
content 1 I told it I want
column 1 to go to
3 that is why the funk is done until the end
and in the others  I put both
arrow 21 in the first or second
column.
The good thing about this fraction
is that it is an automatic calculation that is
quite good, quite efficient
and allows us to do  laws in the way
we want this is very powerful
so we are going to follow
another important concept which is, I really
love
it, it's called screaming jazz it's another way to
define a grid we have this
property grid template arias that what it
allows us to do is define  as a
kind of graphic representation
we would have to do what our grid is going to be like
so if you
see it here we would have two columns the
first column has the header
that is in both the first and the
second then in the
left column we would have the content of the
other side of the side and the future
also behaves like heather up to 100%
of the screen
as we define so where does each
item go
good we have this property grid area
basically I tell the header to put it
in the header
at least because they're not happy and so
same for more
we see this and it will be exactly the
same as the previous example another way to
define a town
exactly the same
he allows us to do things that have not been
designed, he says in the end
we want the future above and the axis of work
rests with the designers,
well
we do that.  simple that
allows us to do very cool things now
we are going to see another type of positioning
we can also define where the
content goes according to its name now
we are going to see
how we came here
these kits that we define in full
ideas we can use it
when we select where  we want
our elements to go now let's
see
for example we have a law that we want to
put in that grid that is outside
of anything else I say apart well
I tell him you know I want it to be in
the column where the content begins
this is the quiz  start script and script in
would be to put me where the
content is where you think content and this
is here that we define in grit temple
tare  so then I want this double and
this where the content begins where
the content ends and in the rows
I want it to be where heather begins
and where she does not look at the content
if we see it
but it is a law that just
begins in the header and ends in the
content against the rows and
starts where the content starts in the
columns and ends the content that
we define this we can
easily change it too
well I still want it to go to the
future
and it goes to the future
or anything we could well this
from the example of the  fasting
we can put whatever we want let's say
answer with we have suter power in
whatever it is possible and it's that easy
we have to change the structure of the
free we are they put it
anywhere total the css is in charge
of all
support
and we are complicated  this
description from yesterday
there is a lot of red out there surprisingly
internet
explorer supports it quite well which is a
s  surprise for me for everyone the only
bad thing is that it has a slightly
different syntax than what we are seeing now
in chrome and firefox actually this is
red but good because it is supported
we have to enable it with a flyer
to show as safari they also
support it in addition  well we are still
screwed this is
quite a new aspect that is still
changing so well we are going to have
to adapt and wait a bit but
well at some point we are going to be able to
use it as it is but since we inhabit it
from firefox
well we don't see anything but  we have to
work with an end and although I don't read anything
I think it is law at point c that is the
gray point
and level and we have to do it between
for chrome with flags
and we have to enable to
experiment it features because all the
examples if not  they all look the same you do
n't see anything at all but well we
can start using it to try
little things if you want to do it it
's pretty good
good everything  these were quite
simple examples of what gray gray is with a
fairly normal and expected law but what
about the real world well
I found this site that seemed
quite good to be able to enable it
with grids because it has many of the
things that we could get to  recreate
this way if we see it
this is the simple stop site
and if we see it in
normal mobile with one column the articles at
100%
well I said well we could see
how to recreate this in grids well
this is the sketch that tells me we can
define on the one hand the grid lines
we have these three now I am going to tell
you why in this example I do not use grid apps
and that is why
we have one of 28 pixels above and another one
of 18 pixels here this is something that
is not contemplated in the green  rose that
I proposed it in fact they did not give me a ball
but to be able to specify different
grit rose
grit rose gaps with gaps of different
pixel sizes in this case I had
to do it because  and how they were different
or they put them both at 28 at 18 pixels
speed in the old way that we saw
before contents
and the last green line
and at stop
here we do have the 50 pixel gap they
are oops the 50 pixel gap for both
the columns  compare the roses then
we can use grid up and we have the gdr the
banner
content on the left and content on the
right
we are going to see a little how
this is this is the hug the truth yes quite
ugly because we are in this but let's say
that
this is the example  last I don't know if
we are going to look
good then there we define imagine
this in mobile because this would be leo
for mobile we define a container that
is grid
we follow our rows and columns there
is the auto value that explains to us that it
would be good to explain what it is
basically we define a  row in
which we do not know how much the height
of the content is going to be, so we say
auto that contained the height of the development height is
going to be the height of its
content  gone
later we have 28 pixels of grid that
is up to this gap
another car that would be all of
the articles with the articles
18 pixels of gap and another car to make
a triplet of articles
I also say that the columns - 100%
so  so much it takes me 100% of the
screen
and then basically what I did is
position each element of the container
that would come to be this red one they went to the
container both are in the one of chris
lowe one as we said we
can also ignore this
and it will be seen  the same
and then we have the content that is
on road 3 and ends at 4
and content 2 that is on network 5 and
also 6 a bit of an English father
that he had
and that's all, we already have the medium armed
for when we want it  see the layout of
this
if we see this example
we have it is quite similar to what
is the live site
we are in mobile we go to the average and from
stop
we define a max wheat and we center it in
1,064 that gives the size that was set
in it  site  or real and we define on the one hand
the rows that are going to be automatic in
both cases the two rows because because
our content we do not know if it is going to
have more than one article it can have one it
can have four because it has twenty
then we want it to be automatic
where we define  a fixed height
and we can also define it in this
case as we saw the columns in
percentages we have 40 percent
for the first column and 60% for the
second we
position the elements
and we have something more interesting in the
content
content 1 and contents are nestor
grids each one of them
therefore all their children are going to be
bought as grids
for the case of the contents in stop
what we define is a gap of 10 pixels
that we want
here we take out the father in which we had
dance  and we put that the columns
are, we have them at 50% each,
therefore it looks like this, we could easily change it, we
could put 30 and 70, so if
we do
and  we would have a little bit
different data if we wanted to do it
then well this is a real example
of how we could implement it at the
time there is support
we
are still difficult on this topic but
well I wanted to give you a
fairly quick explanation of how it works it
seems to me that  it is something that has a lot of
potential and in a few years when it is
really alive and can be used it is going to
solve our lives a little for all of us
you can download this talk by miguel
house also in pdf and all the examples
that we saw are in
me for  unha if you also want to
follow me on twitter sometimes I write things
and everything is clear
[Applause]